in the last episode you created a web
app
in cloud run backed by a cloud sql
database
yes and it's an app that pulls
developers preferences
for tabs or spaces in their code
everything works but i'm not sure about
how scalable it is
no one is yet that's why we need to run
some load tests
my favorite tool for this is a python
library called locust io
oh i've heard of that uh let's see
python3 and pip okay
i'm installing it now great
i also sent you another file earlier
called locus file dot pi
ah yep i have it right here what does
this file do
exactly it creates two types of users
one that views the home page and one
that casts votes
and now with the weight attribute we've
told locus io to send
five times as many homepage views as
votes cast
most apps are pretty read heavy though
so i thought that might mimic your
user's behavior uh five to one yeah that
ratio sounds about right okay great
in that case you can run locust dash f
locus file dot pi to start the process
alrighty
starting it cool and the locus server is
now running so if you click on the
linkages printed in your terminal
we'll be ready to start the test
alrighty open that one
ah okay number of users um
i'll start with 50 spawn rate what's
that
the spawn rate controls how quickly
locus should reach full throttle
so if you enter a value of 10 locus
would reach 50 concurrent users in five
seconds
all right cool and then for url
i will grab that from the live url
over here paste that in
and this is neat i'm going to release
the swarm
okay so it's sending data to the app
if i click here on charts ah
right here i see the traffic ramping up
uh response times okay
a bit of a long response time right
there in the beginning but then it's
plateauing out
uh pretty good response times the sub
second response times
it looks like it's holding up pretty
well especially since we deployed this
app to europe
and we're running this test from
california
but we should take a peek at how things
are running on the server
let's see here i'll go into cloud run
all right so i'm scrolling down here
checking out
container memory memory utilization
uh looks like it's at a pretty healthy
level uh
but of course klebgrane is serverless so
it would add more resources
if they were needed so cloudron should
really always be healthy
right and to that point the real
question we're here to answer is how
your database is holding up
ah okay switching to the database in the
console now
going into the poll database
cpu was very low then we created the
the database so that was took a lot of
cpu then it was very low here when it
did nothing
and then we started the test right
around here it looks like cpu is
still pretty low even though we're
putting a lot of load on it
let's have a look at memory
[Music]
memory usage is holding steady around
600 megabytes
and our server has 3.75 gigabytes
so memory is also healthy and remember
since you're not launched yet if it
shows high cpu or memory it would be
very easy to increase those
for your data brace while there are
still no users to care about downtime
oh sounds good but what if i have
launched my app
and the database is struggling what
should i do then
i usually follow a four-step plan to
ensure that my apps perform well
oh i love ordered lists first the
obvious place to start
is optimizing your actual database
queries things like making sure every
column involved in a where clause has an
underlying database index or that
frequently run
expensive queries like counts are
denormalized if possible
that's great to keep in mind but what
should i do if my app is still slow
after optimizing all of my queries
it's true that optimization can only get
you so far
so the second step is to simply add more
cpus or memory to your database instance
this is often the simplest fix
however even that runs into limits for
example making your main database larger
won't necessarily help an app that
performs well in one hemisphere but
poorly in the other
and so my third step is to add read
replicas potentially in different
regions if your users are global
okay this makes sense so far and it
sounds like these steps would
accommodate most applications
what's the last step the last step is to
introduce partitioning or sharding to
your database
but you should never attempt these
solutions until you've exhausted all of
your simpler options
because these are the most complicated
to do correctly oh that list is really
helpful
my users incessantly refresh the page to
track which team is winning tabs or
spaces
so i'm optimistic about read replicas
could we set one up
for sure to set up a read replica click
on your cloud sql instance
and then click on the replicas tab on
the left all right
replicas yep
select the create read replica button in
the middle
very nice
and all of these default values should
be good so you can press create all
right
[Music]
now this will take several minutes to
catch up to your production database
now that your replica is ready navigate
back to your cloud run service
and click on the edit and deploy a new
revision button
all right here's my poll service
i'm clicking it edit and deploy a new
version all right i'm clicking it
and on that page select the connections
tab
connections uh very good
ah cloud sequel connections yeah right
there
you can press add connection and select
your new replica
ah there is my poll database replica
once you deploy this you'll be ready to
route your select queries to that
replica in your application code
as you see fit oh that sounds excellent
do you have any advice on how to do that
where to route queries
yes first and foremost read replicas can
only receive
read queries so select statements insert
or update
queries cannot go to your read replicas
they will fail
and they must go to the primary database
now just be aware
if you write to the main database and
then immediately trying to read those
same
rows from your replica you may not get
the latest data
and in this situation you must also send
those select queries
to your main database all right
i'll work the read replica into my
application code later
for now i think i'm ready to launch
congratulations your mvp is out the door
and now begins the long process of
adding new bugs
i mean features maybe you write bucks
craig
but i prefer not to well if you prefer
not adding bugs then you might want to
plan ahead for your eventual changes to
your database schema
with a distributed infrastructure like
cloud run it's critical to keep database
schema updates
out of your application startup code why
is that
well some developers run database schema
updates like creating new tables or
columns as part of their application
launch
but for example let's say the next
version of your application needs a
country table
if this table is created by your
framework when it starts
multiple cloud run instances could
simultaneously detect that the table is
missing and attempt to create and
populate it
some of those queries could fail or you
could end up with a countries table full
of duplicate
records oh i see i usually run all of my
database schema changes a
separate cloud build step when i build
my new container
perfect that's definitely the right way
to handle it
cool i feel a lot more confident about
pairing cloud sql and cloud run
now let's see if i can remember all of
the important tips
first i load test and profile my app to
measure performance
as needed i apply the optimization steps
second to avoid conflicts i make sure
that my database schema updates
don't run on application startup that's
it
with those steps cloud run and cloud sql
can be a great pairing
like cheese and wine or peas and carrots
or dare i say like tabs and spaces
what no you don't mix tabs and spaces
what's wrong with you craig
[Music]
you